hey guys let's roll
looks like a refrigerator loving
all right we're coming up on to my
favorite booboo
of course the OSS gave me and I
I showed you guys this previously and
it's awesome because
yep and it won't find anything it's
really good
I just bought him in that pod
I was joking I'm like if this is a nap
pod I'm so into this
in it
with artisanal farms like Taiwan Japan
try to best tea in the world
they have the machine we will develop
the recipe for us and with them
so this is the DGI DJ booth every time I
say it I run all the letters together so
you guys know the drill that I have an
advance me three the professional
version
I've been wanting to try this Joey so
it's kind of like a little it basically
would be like a steady steady camp and
you can link up to your phone here what
yes sir the new vodka - I know
coming to a theater
coming soon to a YouTube channel
probably mixing I don't I'm sure little
be unlikely to version 3.0 4k video
though they're filming on my friend
Mason camera I'm going to fight you
this is so neat it's really neat that we
need to make it happen
this is so great
Francesca's neck is broken
sneak peek at the bureau booth because
they're coming out with really
watch that you can connect to your bb-8
and you can control him with like
gesture control oh my gosh bb-8 is here
bb-8 here
can I get a picture PPA oh my gosh and
you can see he just likes to keep the
force which brings him from a stable
boat into driving and then fluidly
follows his motions as he moves around
but he's linked directly to the robot
between the phase and boy you guys are
not gonna believe us right now I am in
this room with Susan Bennett who is the
boy a serious very she's very mysterious
you know seriously
the other see really guys sometimes a
heavily in the mail Australia never met
I've never met that I mean you know all
of these series would change with the
other seven system
British and the French
yeah what's your favorite serious paper
football all my favorite phrases I don't
know and I don't care
I'm kidding I'm kidding guys thank you
oh hey so I really didn't even end up
filming anything else at CES it was so
extremely busy we went from one event to
event hanging out on the show floor
seeing all kinds of crazy stuff so I
hope you guys enjoyed this very random
vlog I now have to get my puppy ready
for the dog Awards that you're gonna win
today
ha good boy you're such a good man
I'll see you guys in the next video let
me know what you would like to see me
cook next as I need to do some cooking
videos this week so let me know I'll see
you later